Right now, somewhere in the universe, a giant
star is detonating, creating a huge cosmic
explosion called a supernova.
Supernovas are a big, giant, dramatic end to
a star's life.
All stars die, but only the biggest go out
with a bang.
For a star to go supernova, we think it has
to be at least eight times more massive than
our sun.
It's so easy to think of our sun as this
incredibly gigantic thing.
But our son is absolutely tiny compared to
some of the giant stars in the sky.
We can see some of these giant stars with the
naked eye.
And the 10th brightest in the night sky is a
red supergiant around 15 times the mass of
the sun. Beetlejuice.
Beetlejuice is so big that if you were to
place it in our own solar system, it would
stretch to the orbit of Jupiter.
This is one of the biggest beasts in the
galaxy.
It's a star also that is on the verge of
death.
Beetlejuice is less than 10 million years
old, but this huge star's days are numbered.
It's ready to blow.
And when it does, we'll see a region of sky
brighten for 14 days until it's nearly as
bright as a full moon.
It is going to be one of the most spectacular
shows in history.
And it could happen at any moment.
I mean, this is the thing. I often stand
outside in my yard in the wintertime.
I look up at Orion and I see Beetlejuice and
I'm like, explode.
So what will make Beetlejuice go Supernova?
To understand a giant star's death, we need
to understand its life.
From the day it's born until the day it
dies.
A star's life is a constant battle.
Gravity is pulling in and energy pushing
out.
The interior of a star is fusing countless
atomic nuclei together.
Atoms are ramming into each other, getting
very, very close.
And if they get close enough, they'll
actually stick and form a larger atom.
Every second a giant star fuses seven and one
half billion tons of hydrogen.
That amount of energy is roughly equivalent
to about 100 billion atomic bombs per second.
That's a big ass explosion.
This explosive energy threatens to blow the
star apart.
But the star's own massive gravity keeps the
lid on.
Everything in the universe is a fight between
the inward force of gravity and the outward
force of pressure or energy.
Every single star in the sky.
Even our own sun is an incredibly dynamic
battleground in many ways.
Stars are an explosion that are actually too
big to explode.
Gravity holds it together.
This battle between these two opposing forces
determines the life and death of the star.
And this is where size matters.
The more massive the star, the more gravity
pushes inward and the harder the star has to
push outwards to keep itself alive.
Very massive stars are like stars on
steroids.
They have a lot of fuel to burn.
They're so powerful that they use up their
fuel at a rapid rate.
Massive stars like Beetlejuice are giant
factories fusing lighter elements into
heavier ones.
But the hard work doesn't start until their
final years.
For around 90% of their life, they fuse
hydrogen into helium.
But eventually the hydrogen starts running
out.
In the core of a Supergiant star.
There's a sequence of fusion that goes from
lighter elements to heavier elements, and it
gets faster and faster every step of the
way.
The countdown to death begins.
The inward push from gravity takes over.
Raising the temperature in the core.
Helium starts fusing into carbon.
There's enough helium to last about a
million years, but it too runs out and things
start speeding up.
Carbon gets fused into neon.
That takes about a thousand years.
Neon fusing into silicon.
That takes about one year.
Once it starts fusing silicon into iron,
that takes one day it gets more and more
frantic. It's kind of like a cooking contest
show, whereas the clock is running down.
They're trying to do more and more things
and they get more and more frantic until
Ding! Time's up.
The star is now in its death throes.
Once iron production has started, the clock
is ticking towards the cataclysmic end of
this star.
A giant ball of incredibly dense iron forms
in the middle of the dying star's core.
This iron sphere is several thousand miles
across and unbelievably hot.
It gets so hot there, the temperature almost
becomes meaningless.
I mean, we're talking about a billion
degrees in the center of one of these stars.
This extreme heat is caused by fusion
reactions.
More and more reactions create heavier and
heavier elements, and with each step, less
and less energy is produced until iron is
created.
When you try to fuse iron nuclei together,
that takes energy.
It doesn't generate energy.
So once the core starts to fuse iron, it's
basically stealing its own energy.
The growing iron core sucks more and more
energy from the star.
Gravity continues, pulling in overwhelming
the outward pressure from inside the star.
Everything gets crushed to unimaginable
degrees.
All of a sudden, there's no nuclear reaction
to support the star against the crush of
gravity.
With nothing left holding it up.
The star is doomed.
Gravity winds the edges of the iron core
collapse.
Trillions of tons of dense iron fall inward
at a quarter of the speed of light.
The star has now less than one second left
to live.
Things start to fall apart really quickly.
The core collapse is so fast that the outer
layers of the star don't even have time to
react. They're just hanging there.
It's kind of like Wile E Coyote when a cliff
collapses underneath him and he doesn't even
fall until he notices.
The rest of the star collapses a trillion,
trillion, trillion tons of gas hurtle inwards
following the ion.
Think about the entire mass of the star that
has been held up by nuclear reactions inside.
All of a sudden those nuclear reactions go
away in a split second.
Everything rushes into the middle.
And that sets off the most dramatic
explosion in the universe.
The spectacular death blow can outshine all
of the stars in the galaxy.
But there's a problem.
We still don't fully understand how a
collapsing ball of iron and tons of falling
gas create a giant fireball.
How this collapsing core triggers a massive
explosion is one of the biggest mysteries in
astrophysics.